let's have a look at it together what
I'm going to do is to standard procedure
I'm going to jot down the important
details of the question and then
together we will look back at that table
trace not a spoiler so Venus is 16 years
old and she is at home so 16 things at
home phonogram to play what else do we
know about her she's stood so that
affects her income threshold and so on
for these allowances and she manages
somehow had an impressive amount of
money while she's studying so while
she's a student she has income are 510
dollars per fortnight not bad okay um
she's entitled to get allowance
calculate the amount that you will
receive okay so there are all these
central details let's turn back we are
going to need the table as well as those
few paragraphs underneath the table as
well to try to dissect ons going on okay
so firstly we have a look you might
actually turn back to pages so look at
the smaller table which she tells you
which category she's in and therefore
what the full balance would be if she
qualified for the whole of clean so be
that she's a 16 year old doesn't say
anything about any children and she's at
home what would her full allowance babe
you see it looks like the first one
doesn't it because the first row is
about single door children and under 18
when she is at home okay so what I'm
going to do is another color here so I'm
going to say this means she has full
allowance Oh 200 now when we do say to
2040
yeah yeah yeah okay that looks good
thank you not some cards okay that's
good but I need to account for what the
rest of this information tells me so go
over the page and now we are going to
find out well will she gets full ounce
or not you're probably guessing she does
it I want to work out how much she
actually gets now because of who she is
which of the rows of the table we're
looking at this big long one right it's
big one here which is the resident table
applies to her most of it it looks to me
like it's the very first road you see
that like you know how each road it's
kind of got to Rosita for student orange
boy she's a student okay so therefore
she has a threshold of four hundred
dollars to get the full mouths she's
quite clearly over that threshold okay
but she's also under the threshold for
getting the part allowance do you see
that so I see that she can get up to 400
and she's got is less than seven hundred
eighty dollars a citizen does that make
sense so I see she's going to get a part
of hours so I'm additional money so now
what I need to work out it is well if
she gained a part of hours how much is
her allowance going to get reduced and
that's where now we turn pass the table
and look underneath in those paragraphs
to try and work out which of these some
applies to her we're lucky even better
if this is ever just may be quick it's
the first paragraph right reading with
me for students who earned a fortnightly
income on between 440 the fortnightly
allowance reduces by fifty cents in the
dollar pause is that Venus it's not if
she's gone past she'd not only gone past
the young nitesh off from full ounce
which is 400 she's also gone past the
threshold for getting like that 50 cent
red onion which is what the next
sentence now tells us right for income
above 480 the allowance is reduced by
to the dollar so there's a second kind
of reduction which is bigger and so the
more you earn the more aggressively the
government is going to reduce your
balance so here's the way we're going to
do this pen back in hand we're now going
to work out how much she's got an access
and how much is going to go to back so
because this happens twice remember she
went over to thresholds she went over
the 430 arm and then she also went over
the 480 threshold remember that so
there's going to be an excess over 40
and there's also going to be a second
exits but we handle them differently
because there's a different reduction
for each so the excess over for 80 years
510 take away 4 80 so that looks to be
my kids thirty dollars are you okay with
that you see where I got that from it's
the amount over that it's a difference
there so if that's the excess over for
any there's a reduction that applies
that have a look it's that second
sentence that starts with four income
over on 408 which is this how many sense
of it on 60 says go to clarify that
that's what I'm talking about i'm going
to call this the 60 sent reduction right
sixty cents out of every dollar of the
allowance gets removed so I've got to go
to thing x 60 cents zero dollars 60
and you check that if you calculate up
no I think these are easy enough numbers
I plus 3 times 6 times 6 that's just 18
right now is it going to be 180 or 18 or
1.8 like X then Jason it's clearly gonna
be 80 right so you can do these little
mental tricks for yourself just like 180
HP to be a delay is too small 18 is
Goldilocks just right so there's a 60
set reduction that's the first one but
there's a second what isn't there right
so I'm going to say there's also an
excess over four hundred dollars okay
now this is a bit sneaky please watch
this really carefully right I'm an easy
mistake to make would be to say look she
owns 510 yeah so how much is that over
500 the answer is this I 110 different
to you yeah so it would be a common
sense thing to say and content but in
fact it's not we've already dealt with
30 of those on hundred ten dollars to
notice that we've dealt with that excess
so that thirty dollars I don't need to
worry about it this excess over 400 is
the 480 that's remaining take away 400
that's 80 okay can I say that again
because that went by pretty quickly and
is confusing to people right even though
the total excess over four hundred
dollars is 110 we all saw that okay I've
already dealt with thirty dollars of
that exists right so 110 is when I start
with I've taken off the top 30 and now
there's 80 left right hit so I'm going
to calculate the reduction of this
anyways so now look back at the
paragraph already it's not a 67
reduction its a 50 sir
so for every one of these eight dollars
she's going to lose fifty cents and I
think we can do that one pretty clear
our heads that's just half dollar each
time so that is forty dollars okay now
grab another color if you've got it
there and highlight for yourself because
we just started for thin okay can you
see how important these words is right
for things they're all different and you
do not want to confuse them with each
other here is reduction one that 89 and
here is reduction to now i can combine
those green beans with what her full
allowance would have been and then i'll
work out how much is actually going to
get paid or how much you're actually
going to get wet so now let's you
conclude I would say therefore um how
about whether i guess i take allowance
that's paid
because the whole idea is there is an
allowance that she gets but some of it
is withheld so at least some of it gets
paid it's going to be that to 2040 that
we started with but we're going to take
away both of these reductions the 18 and
the 40 okay this one I cannot do about
it so fine I help me up a hundred and
something 162 m okay tada so you can see
this is this is why I do want to confuse
this with the questions you are doing
last lesson because there's these extra
steps here right you just gotta watch
out like if they pass a threshold and
then they pass another threshold then
you've got to deal with each of those in
turn but the lights of is not more
complicated just try to be a little more
careful with your section with you okay